Master Chief's hero or traitor Spartan
Locke friend or foe epic world's epic
battles epic scale this is halo 5
Guardians hello pod all right halo 5 is
gonna be amazing guys we're so excited
about it we're reckless Tortuga on Jason
Eric Microsoft had a huge press
conference they showed some gameplay a
trailer we actually got the chance to
play the game we got to play halo 5
multiplayer the new mode it's creating
you have two teams but you also have a
non-playable oh yeah that you fighting
against so it's all points based yeah
that's the third element of it is these
characters who are NPCs the multiplayer
maps to seemed so much bigger especially
in the mode we got to play it seemed
like you could get up to maybe 40
players on that it was like
compartmentalize it wasn't very open a
lot of different sections on but I wish
I got to play it more we only really got
to play it for 10-15 minutes yeah but
everyone it was great it was a good no
there's a lot of guns oh yeah the guns
are crazy there's a ton of them and old
guns and I don't know there are some
cool features that I realized story-wise
I think this year one of the big things
that they're doing is Master Chief guns
row Master Chief goes rogue and he's
being hunted by another spark which is
kind of interesting it could be an
interesting gameplay mechanic so we
grabbed is fun but I had the multiplayer
from what I saw from the multiplayer
yeah it's gonna be dope I think we're
gonna barf ending hours on this game I
can already feel it so the game comes
out october twenty seventh Kalos got a
Halloween release October 27 uh yeah
instead of going out trick-or-treating
with my kid I think I'm gonna be playing
halo 5 Jesus I don't want to know how
many Master Chief's are gonna be at
parties oh it's gonna be out of our
control so we're reckless Tortuga this
is hashtag news definitely subscribed to
new media rock stars here because it's
awesome and we've got a ton of videos
that are coming out Eric's dying it's
all this fee three it's getting to me
like and share it subscribe to new media
rock stars for more coverage and to
reckless or too good yeah our YouTube
channel thanks guys access sir huh not
hey we're we're in the same car
and